en este vídeo quiero platicar un poco
cómo afecta a un cambio de radio al
perímetro o bien al área de un círculo
entonces imagínate que tenemos un primer
círculo cuyo radio es equis entonces
aquí voy a poner este círculo y vamos a
pensar que su radio es equis y
específicamente en este vídeo vamos a
ver qué sucede si duplicamos el radio es
decir ahora en vez de tener un círculo
de radio x cuya distancia del centro a
la orilla sea equis vamos a tener un
círculo de radio 2x que sería más o
menos algo de este estilo déjame tomar
la herramienta de círculo para dibujarlo
algo de este estilo vale bueno entonces
ahora el radio es estos x 2 x ok y vamos
a ver qué sucede con el perímetro con el
perímetro de estos dos círculos y con el
área voy a hacer el perímetro en color
verde el perímetro para este círculo lo
podemos calcular a partir de la fórmula
dos por pi por radio el perímetro es
igual a 2
x p x el radio por el radio que sería x2
por pi por equis y de este lado el
perímetro sería igual a 2 por pi por el
radio de acá 2 por pi por el radio de
acá y el radio de acá es 2 x 2 x 2 por 2
es 4 de modo que el perímetro es igual a
4 por pi por ti por x entonces si nos
damos cuenta para pasar de aquí a acá
simplemente multiplicamos por un factor
de 2 sale si el radio se duplica
entonces el perímetro se multiplica por
dos vamos a ver qué sucede con el área
el área la voy a hacer en color azul y
la fórmula del área es la siguiente el
área de un círculo es igual a ti por el
radio al cuadrado sería pi pi
multiplicado por el radio que es x por
equis elevado al cuadrado y por x al
cuadrado y de este lado tenemos que el
radio es 2x de modo que el área es igual
a pi x el radio esto va entre paréntesis
2 x elevado al cuadrado y realizando las
operaciones aquí nos queda que el área
es igual a ti multiplicado por 2 al
cuadrado o sea 4 x x al cuadrado por x
al cuadrado que se puede reescribir como
que el área es igual a 4 x pi por x al
cuadrado y observa que aquí sucede algo
interesante al duplicar el radio ahora
nuestra área nuestra área se multiplicó
por un factor de 4 x
4 por qué crees que suceda esto te
recomiendo detener el vídeo para
pensarlo un poco por tu cuenta
pero bueno básicamente esto sucede por
cómo son las fórmulas de perímetro y de
área en la fórmula de perímetro tenemos
que el perímetro es igual a 2 por pi por
el radio entonces el perímetro el
perímetro depende de manera lineal del
radio sin embargo en la fórmula de área
tenemos que el área es igual a pi pi por
radio al cuadrado entonces aquí la
dependencia es con el radio al cuadrado
el área es directamente proporcional al
radio al cuadrado
entonces si el radio lo multiplicamos
por 2 ese factor de 2 va a salir como 2
al cuadrado como 4 si el radio lo
multiplicamos por 3 va a salir como 9 si
lo multiplicamos por 4 va a salir como
16 y así sucesivamente vale sin embargo
aquí arriba en el perímetro el factor
que le pongamos al radio 23 o lo que sea
va a ser el mismo factor que se aplica
al perímetro vale bueno entonces esta es
la explicación si quieres convencerte un
poco más puedes intentar con algunos
valores de radios o con algunos valores
de que tanto multiplicas el radio si lo
duplican o triplican y así